what did you find out from Paul George
that you didn't know going in Lee Dean I
think there's been so much said about
him not by him you know about what he
wanted and it seemed like what he wanted
was to get out of Indiana and to win and
to go to Los Angeles and the reason that
never made sense is when you think about
where the Lakers are in their own
rebuilding process and if you really
wanted to win you know to compete for
titles right away I think it begs the
question why the Lakers so that was sort
of the main question I had for him is
you know how he sort of reconciled those
things and I guess I learned is that the
winning really is the priority and if he
feels like the Lakers is a place where
he can do that where he can recruit
other players where he can kind of get
the snowball rolling then yeah the
Lakers and become obviously an appealing
destination for some buddies from LA but
if he doesn't feel like the balls
rolling there and it's just Lonzo ball
and Brandon Ingram then I think he's
going to take a hard look at some other
options and I think Oklahoma City is
going to be one of them what does he
know about Russell Westbrook as far as
playing with him and you know the pros
and cons of that he didn't know anything
he didn't know anything about anybody
really in Oklahoma City I mean this is a
guy who has no idea I don't think of you
know the outpouring that's going to
greet him when he gets there yes trying
to think about as a player ever left a
start a player of Durant caliber ever
left a city and been replaced within a
year by a player who you know may not be
that high of an echelon but is right
there you know is he in that top 10
class and you're looking at you're
talking about sort of a year-long
courting process now between Oklahoma
City and Paul George and that's going to
be an unusual experience for somebody
who didn't go to Kentucky or North
Carolina or anywhere like that you know
the Pacers have great crowds but they
weren't the only show in town I think
this is going to be an unusual
experience for George starting today
when he lands there but he's open to
that possibility right no doubt yeah I
don't even think that that felt like lip
service of course I'm going to say that
because I don't want to be booed the
first night I'm there where I say no hey
alright right you can't say
he can't say I'm leaving but I honestly
don't believe I say he is fully open I
mean if you look at the comments in
there it's pretty candid I mean I think
he is looking for a place where he can
win a title when multiple titles and if
it works with him in Westbrook I mean he
even said if it works to the tune of
Conference Finals and potentially
upsetting the Warriors you know meshing
with Westbrook and I think they I think
he realizes he's seen enough of
Westbrook to know that it could be a fit
for him I mean he doesn't need the ball
in his hands all the time he's a good
cutter off the ball he'll space the
floor he can defend he can even defend
some opposing point guards so I think
that the basketball fit is there now
what is it like playing with Russell
Westbrook and will they be a match
that's all kind of to be determined and
that's why it's hard to read tea leaves
with any of these guys a year out a lot
of times we'll look at a player and say
his personality fits a city and vice
versa we thought that with Kevin Durant
that the personality his personality
maybe was so low-key he suddenly signed
one day and it took like a minute wasn't
a big deal there was a little bit of a
press q no we just kind of went all
Kevin Durant resigned Paul George
playing in Indiana not playing at a
basketball powerhouse is his personality
more suited to Oklahoma City than it
would Los Angeles know there's kind of a
duality to him I mean he he loves LA
idolized Kobe Bryant you're talking
about somebody who feels I think a lot
of players don't really care that much
about playing at home he does have a
real connection to where he's from to
his family but on the same by the same
token he actually grew up in a place
that is maybe more like Oklahoma City
than what people think of his LA I mean
he grew up in Palmdale he fishes but I
got to say all of that stuff I think and
kind of distract and you know those are
sort of you know superficial factors
there things that are fun to talk about
in the end I think for Westbrook
I think we all looked at it as oh he
likes fashion and he's from LA he won't
like Oklahoma City but in reality
Oklahoma City became perfect for kind of
the deeper levels of his personality
like you know a guy who's slow to trust
the guy who's resistant to change
Oklahoma City became a comfortable home
and there I don't think George really
you not have known anything besides
Indiana I think this is going to be a
chance to kind of see the way a totally
different organization operates a
totally different kind of practice
facility there's all of these things
that now Oklahoma City is a chance in
this year-long courting process to
impress him with it's all about winning
and the timeframe of the Lakers winning
I think by most experts estimates the
Lakers aren't going to be a very good
team this upcoming season that could be
interesting but they're not going to be
a very good team did Paul George talk
about what he needed to see specifically
with Los Angeles before you're going to
commit long term to them no I mean he
wasn't getting into like the development
of Ingram and bald
I think he'll need to still need the
sense that he won't be alone someone's
going to be the apt to be the first one
on the boat you know if you're kind of
looking to put together one of those
super teams but they're going to have to
max Lots next summer and there's no
doubt if he felt as if it would be him
and someone else that probably you know
fits the description that he gave of a
snowball forming of you know feeling
like other guys we're going to we're
going to jump on but I think listen I
think that the weight ball plays the way
Ingram plays those are going to be those
are going to be major factors you know
when LeBron went from Cleveland to Miami
the first when he left in 2010 he kept
an eye on those young guys on Kyrie
Irving and Tristan Thompson and so he
sort of knew what he was getting into
when he went back if George is serious
about the Lakers is everybody you know
will have you believe I'm sure he'll be
keeping an eye on them as well you know
as many times you profiles and bran
James I have to ask you the mindset he
left Cleveland once left Miami then goes
back to Cleveland do you think it's in
LeBron James to have one more big move
you know I don't know Dan I said I never
seen never with players especially when
you think about you know how quickly
these windows closed and how much the
championships are the priority for
someone like LeBron I mean he sees that
window and he doesn't want to leave and
give them on the table
I still think you know as much as talked
about with him in the Lakers also
where he is in the Eastern Conference
right now still to me gives him kind of
the cleanest look at a title but clearly
this Warriors dynamic has created a
situation in the NBA where two stars is
no longer enough three might be if you
have the right cast around you but to me
the Warriors have sort of changed
everything where I think you know
everybody's sort of looking around and
thinking you know are we really going to
just play out the string of our careers
with the Warriors winning every title or
are we going to kind of be proactive and
do something about it to sort of match
them and it that's probably I mean
moving forward I think that will have to
be on LeBrons radar because this is not
someone who just wants to spend the
remaining years of his prime finishing
second good stuff is always Lee thanks
for joining us thank you Dan ticker as
Lee Jenkins Sports Illustrated the
profile on Paul George the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience